hello everybody and welcome to part 7 of
let's play amnesia the Dark Descent now
where we left off
I had just kicked the ass of a bad
monster and sent him out into the back
hall I'm gonna follow him try to find
him and then punch him in his face some
more all right where are you come here
you stupid dog mana I guess he's gone
yeah yeah
why is it everywhere I got the pieces
I got
nothing ah time is something no key this
thing no yes no yes am i stupid
quite possibly ah I miss the key
somewhere I'm an idiot all right
oh yeah while I was pretending to be
scared from the monster I suppose holy
crap uh would oh yeah that was weird
let's spend like a cat you know leaving
a headless bird outside my door the
monster you know respects me so much I
just want to give me a president I can
understand that
now where is the key remember the memory
was like something about a key
shirts lots of shirts I must have her
Daniel I'm not Daniel Daniel must have
loved his shirts who didn't a box baba
already look through this
intercept ah whiskey it's angry
hey ah they got chandelier
rabbit go a rabbit I'm too interesting
here but I am smart I'll show you God oh
hey Oh
ha ha ha tada
thank God there it is I guess it is a
good place to hide it then yeah no
kidding Daniel took me only ten seconds
to find it alright
machine room to the machine room and any
time now either we are right on our way
sorry for the long load times I don't
know what's going on my computer's a
beast it shouldn't be at
ah Dickie flavors but an old friend back
in our cheer gave me I'm here why isn't
he with us didn't he want to come
he wanted to Daniel with
things don't always turn out the way we
planned no they don't listen sometimes
you get pulsing read Saxon plus in your
fountain and then your baby pukes that's
just wrong
the game is sick left
yes must use the key I'm smart
alrigh machine room lots of pipes ah ah
no never mind
Ellis Melton knows he's testing you guys
see no Smith of July 1839 today I went
to the University looking for answers I
was able to sneak into Herbert's office
and pick up an address book along with
some relevant textbooks aha
professor Taylor that the Faculty of
history was very helpful and I managed
to approach the subject of the orbs
they're all the most imagining cific was
the prevalent trace they had left in our
culture the mythic orbs may in fact have
inspired the globus crucita which so
many royal regalia holds to this day in
ancient times huh orbs were held by
priests as a symbol of the Sun and its
power yes I was leaving I ever heard a
disturbing conversation so William Smith
the geologist was killed last night
right less than a fortnight had passed
Beyonce's expertise I know it's silly
but I can't help feeling responsible
somehow you are I can't believe someone
stole your journal just to throw it
around in random places across the
entire map
actually not even thrown just leave him
gently in nice neat places where they
can be easily found
what is this pressure oh um what are the
things that I yeah yeah nope
see ah aha
I'll bait down it I could remember that
let's be stupid
three uh hey good enough uh I won't do
all right
down and down right that's eight on the
bottom
and six
you
for dammit dumb I am dumb
that's alright
Oh uh-huh I see this is how it's done
hi everyone knows this is so silly
that's not right either oh lordy I'm
embarrassing myself in front of all of
YouTube because I can't figure out a
simple some engineering student I am
yeah - - ha done ha ha
who's smart I am come here tinder box my
reward you to be so shy yay anyone know
there's not Daniel shut up the second or
second puzzle but I'm just gonna blow
right through I'm so smart and strong
and handsome
not Daniel though he okay right circle
in circle peg
yeah
ah was that a successful noise I don't
think it was
wait a minute with this no not you
Trinity for phase complete steam flow
cycle gotcha
Trinity for phase flow cycle yeah that
was wait how the noise is the same but
that's what it said I'm gonna go with
that
yep yeah this one good all right what
next what possible challenge could there
be for me yeah that's right
where you're a whole lever a child
Oh
all right boxes on a box on a box yeah
box eat it eat it oh well I guess is
where I go insane nope I got away
aha half the lanterns worth more than
half a knock
damn it well I wasted that you all can
laugh at me in the comments if you'd
like rock oh cool
aha engineering students I know exactly
what that is
burn oh go greedy right give you what
you want
dirty dirty bird take that that enough
yeah Oh more God
me me me there
booyakasha aha
let's see
hi-yah work ha oh I saw cogwheel I know
ha ha [ __ ] [ __ ] come here
ha ha ha
does it matter they're probably all the
same anyway don't judge me
Barrow ah boxes yeah behind there nope
cog ha
running back up you know this would be
more except ah
cogwheel Chuck you down there last one
three ha oh I'm a genius
Oh who's awesome me I am look at me
right away with no problem at all
it was just that good yeah you can all
tell me it's okay
yeah yeah shut up
smart smart nice work booyah ah yeah
14th of July 18 30 million yeah yeah
I've read every book I can find on the
subject or big were rich in legend and
hearsay my knowledge is lack for the
insight I crave hour for Bailey letters
too many in Herbert's address book and
received answers of varying important
what it dick today I got one which
differed greatly from the others from a
baron in Prussia Prussia said nothing
about the quaint stories of priests in
underground temples I agree it didn't
even mention them he simply wrote I know
I can protect you know he come to
brennenburg castle don't do it signed
Alexandre bastard what am I to make of
this
nothing protect me from what the
darkness someone after me yes I looked
up brennenburg and traced it to the
Prussian woods near the Baltic Sea wow
you loving the nest informative letter
I've received it causes me greatest
distress and interest I decide right my
thoughts are drawn to my nightmares the
most disturbing sound calls to me boom a
sound defying description a voice from
the void the dark near last few weeks
have been awful with so many sleepless
nights dreading a repeat of those horrid
dreams from the darkness I shall visit
my physician dr. Tate and hope that he
can provide me with sedatives to help me
sleep my buddy's gonna die because of
you Daniel you're such an [ __ ]
all right maybe I'm too hard on this guy
he's been through a lot
here's to the old monsters and stuff
even though I'm helping him every step
of the way did I not do this right
what's going on here flow believe
there's another word behind Fluxus
whatever all right looking in the
journal again
bah-bah machine will not work until all
rods are inserted all right I guess I'm
just gonna do a little bit of trial and
error here those Trinity for phase and
flow let's ride Trinity flowing for
phase didn't sound right all right now
start with red on the left and alternate
to blue in the yellow I don't care what
do you all think this is the way I'm
gonna do it you're all gonna want or you
can just fast-forward I actually get it
either way is fine with me huh yeah god
I'm so smart
due to do dear dear - dear doodly-doo to
do and booyah
yeah who's the man I am NOT you Daniel
you don't know what take an elevator
ride down into
oh good this is a time to move faster
Daniel
okay ah clearly after you you should
probably go pass out oh right yes
awesome
I don't know how the darkness can create
red goop shouldn't it be black goop
something a bit more ominous I know it's
uh huh huh what bah oh boy I guess I'm
going one way but there wasn't any big
secret back there huh ha
all right on my way down
nothing gonna stop me now
oh I know what's coming out behind one
of these doors there's going to be a
monster it's going to bang on the brain
ten bucks
yes Oh
option B with
that was that was gaming option be a
enemy pops up in one of the greats
be you crash I should have guessed be
alright this looks promising
I like it not a scratch on me yeah that
elevator oh yeah I survived that cuz I'm
so tough yeah that's right
alright this is the arm come this way
who's not give me I should have warned
you
one of my responsibilities as a baron is
that of a prison warden oh yes sure this
is where criminals are locked up alright
yeah dungeon
very much oh come don't linger all right
anyway that's the end of part 7 thanks
so much for watching
stick around I'm going to be going right
into partay so thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time